le salon de l'agriculture est ouvert on
en a parlé ouverture dans un contexte de
crise c'est le thème de la voix est
libre aujourd'hui deuxième partie on
retrouve arnaud lefebvre et ses invités
élus et représentants du monde agricole
sa se passe en direct dans le plateau
juste à côté
merci emmanuel nous invite effectivement
ça mais le grand pour les jeunes
agriculteurs christian decerle président
de la chambre d'agriculture de bourgogne
franche comté et puis invités politiques
françois patriat sénateur de côte-d'or
et puis rémy de lattes député de la
côte-d'or question arrivait sur internet
elle résume bien la compétitivité les
problèmes de prix également pour
l'agriculture française
les céréales nous exportons des céréales
en egypte par exemple l'egypte ne veut
plus de nos céréales parce qu'elles
n'ont pas un taux de protéines suffisant
10e téléspectateurs apparemment bien
informés sur la question parce que les
sols en france ont été trop puiser
pompée par l'agriculture c'est un
problème mondial
est ce sa vie c'est une réalité est-ce
qu'on est plus compétitif est ce que les
pays ne veulent plus nos produits c'est
pas c'est pas une histoire de puiser
trop les sols aujourd'hui on a la
protection de l'eau
les nitrates qui nous réglemente sur
l'apport d'azoté
c'est un peu technique mais et on en met
moins
donc moi je lui à 300 % d'accord pour
protéger l'eau par contre ce qui fait la
protéine dans le blé c'est la zot
donc quand vous mettez moins d'azoté
vous avez moins de protéines et on a une
norme de meunerie on doit voir 11 % de
protéines dans le blé est aujourd'hui
depuis trois ans et ça commence à être
récurrent on est tout juste et donc non
l'autre blé ne sont plus aux normes
d'exportation et même en france via un
meunier veut humble et de 11 % de
protéines
donc c'est un problème il faut arriver à
réengager de la recherche et à remettre
de la protéine dans nos blés passe pour
qu'on soit compétitifs à l'exportation
et qu'on ait des blés meuniers
en france il y avait une qualité
mondiale qui soit possible d'être vendu
ses râles où elle va globalement restant
de ça le problème de compétitivité sur
les agriculteurs français
oui il faut ce qu'on l'a on l'a déjà
évoqué dans le cadre de cette émission
ceci étant dit nos produits même si
ponctuellement à peuvent rencontrer un
problème particulier nos produits sont
quand même convoité se positionne bien
sûr des marchés à l'export alors pas
tous mais ici en bourgogne
enfin à dijon regardez l'excédent que
génère dans la balance commerciale les
vins spiritueux
donc je pense que de ce côté là les
agriculteurs français où les
viticulteurs français sont plutôt bien
positionnée sur l'image du produit
le problème c'est d'être compétitif sur
le plan économique
l'image des produits oui c'est vrai le
grand oui par rapport à la compétitivité
il ya quelque chose qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à faire passer
on parlait normalisation monsieur
patriat régler les charges n'étaient pas
importantes mais les charges directes
peut-être c'est à nous de jouer dessus
mais les charges indirectes
aujourd'hui quand vous mettez un tas de
fumier à l'abri ça coûte une
exploitation laitière il faut une
fumière couverte ou une fosse de
récupération justement pour protéger les
eaux mais il n'y a pas la petite line
comme vous quand vous allez chez le
garagiste ou sait marquer
recyclage des filtres aujourd'hui quand
on vend un litre de lait on met pas la
petite ligne de un ou deux centimes
préservation de la qualité de l'eau en
france et il ya un moment il va falloir
qu'on passe par ça peut-être pour dire
ben on veut un pays propre
nous on fera les efforts on les a déjà
fait sa vie et évoqué aujourd'hui et on
est capable de le faire
par contre on peut pas tirer sur nos
revenus ou ne plus avoir de rentabilité
sur nos exploitations pour ça donc il
faut que la france le consommateur
accepte de payer la qualité de l'eau la
qualité de l'air et tout ce qui s'ensuit
prévu de la tête oui je pense que je
pense effectivement que c'est les
dispositions qui ont été prises par la
profession pour limiter la pollution
elles sont vraiment évidente depuis très
longtemps bien avant qu on parle d co
agriculture et j'ai le sentiment
aujourd'hui par contre que on veut aller
trop vite quand on impose aux
agriculteurs par exemple de réduire le
niveau des nitrates c'est le paysan il
va pas dépenser de l'argent comme ça
pour pour mettre de la zone dont sa
culture n'a pas besoin par contre ce
qu'il faut faire en même temps s'est
développée de la recherche pour faire en
sorte que l'on puisse trouver des
éléments palliatifs de la baisse
d'utilisation de certains produits
l'interdiction de certains titres
sanitaires faute de quoi le paysan
n'arrivera plus effectivement à assurer
la qualité qui qui est celle des
produits agricoles d'une manière
générale en france qualité voulue par
les consommateurs on le voit jamais eu
autant de succès pour les filières
courtes pour les magasins de vente
directe pourquoi n'at-il pas plus
finalement de ce genre de magasin
christian decerle il ya eu des réunions
avec la grande distribution à louhans ya
pas longtemps pour mettre tout le monde
autour de la table et la grande
distribution dit on n'a pas la demande
enfin si on peut pas avoir assez de
production les agriculteurs ne nous
donne pas assez de viande pour mettre
dans nos rayons
c'est vrai c'est l'offre qu'elle
suffisante alors c'est pas la demande et
l'offre ça lorsque un an l'offre des
exécutants n'est pas suffisante pour
répondre à la demande des consommateurs
je partage tout à fait ce qu'a dit tout
à l'offre soit patriat on a là la chance
dans ce pays d'avoir d'abord
diversité de territoires de région avec
chacune leur originalité leur
particularité
c'est un atout c'est un atout qui nous
est enviée c'est un petit joyau qu'il
faut aussi être préservé donc je pense
aussi qu'il faut pas opposer des modèles
c'est à dire il n'ya pas les industries
agroalimentaires qui seraient les grands
méchants et puis le circuit court et le
bio qui seraient des systèmes vertueux
ménages recommencent rémission après mme
demaret mériterait aussi peut-être
d'être dit c'est qu'on a quelques
exemples qui porte à réflexion et qui
sont encourageants je pense à un groupe
d'agriculteurs qui fournit à leclerc
dans le département saône-et-loire joue
je pense même à deux groupes
d'agriculteurs où on a contractualisé à
l'année sur un prix constant qui ne
fluctuent pas comme malheureusement on
voit si souvent les produits à la
production fluctuer et c'est du gagnant
gagnant du producteur jusqu'au
consommateur parce qu'on volumes
commercialisés
on tient à des bons niveaux de volume le
distributeur le consommateur est donc
content le distributeur a passé un deal
aig des agriculteurs qui tiennent parole
approvisionne 52 semaines par an donc on
peut aussi réussir
ceci étant dit ceci étant dit on vit
aussi avec les habitudes on vit aussi
avec la foulée de ce qu on était trente
glorieuses aujourd'hui en matière de
restauration collective et de
restauration hors foyer
mais comment on peut imaginer avec le
nombre de contraintes exigences de
normes qu'on impose du côté de la
production qu'on puisse redécouvrir des
scandales du type de la viande de cheval
par exemple donc y'a il ya des secteurs
où les choses se clarifient se précise
il ya encore des secteurs où il ya
vraiment du chemin à parcourir
et à ce niveau là c'est un petit peu
comme les farines de viande qu'ils
avaient été dénoncés et qu'on a et dont
on a rendu responsables les agriculteurs
les éleveurs mais on croit les pauvres
éleveurs étaient en quoi que ce soit
engagé
dans le non respect de la réglementation
du niveau de chauffage des farines de
viande
donc si vous voulez ont tous les jours
on nous renvoie des questions
d'organisation dont certaines nous sont
imputables et dans lesquels on doit
s'engager
d'autres c'est plus une action
collective dans lesquelles tout le monde
doit aussi faire des efforts je sais pas
si je m'exprime clairement et aussi
voulait lancer intéressant sur ses repas
au foyer justement milliards d'euros 1,3
en france prix hors foyer ça veut dire
qu'il ya du travail là se dire que les
collectivités peuvent s'engager à faire
revenir les collectivités lycée agricole
d'auxerre la brosse à côté d'auxerre il
achète la viande de boeuf en demi
carcasses ce qu'ils ont fait c'était une
volonté du conseil d'administration ils
ont embauché un cuisinier donc l'état le
politique la région la région les listes
a fait le choix d'embaucher un cuisinier
qui sait travailler la viande c'est des
deux ou trois producteurs qui
approvisionne localement on sait d'où ça
vient ça fonctionne et travailler et ça
fonctionne donc il ya aussi ça et on est
sur un coût qui peut être peut-être un
peu plus élevés etc c'est aussi ça qu'il
faut voir il faut que le consommateur
donc le parent d'élève acceptent de
payer peut-être son repas un peu plus
cher pour derrière créer de la valeur
on a un gars qui bossent et derrière on
a des producteurs locaux qui arrive à
mieux valoriser les collectivités
françois patriat la région s'engage
notamment auprès des rectorats pour les
lycées est ce que vous savez
concrètement comment vous mangez au
sénat par exemple en spa avec la toile
halles c'est la région directement avec
tous ses placements a dit qu'elle allait
sensibiliser les rectorats pour les
patients de boire et twilight aura l'a
fait avec nous et nous avons mis en
place plusieurs sections pour que nos
lycées soit exemplaire et travaille avec
les produits totaux on a mis en place
téléphone maintenant une application qui
s'appelle locale qui permet à tous les
producteurs de fast gear en ligne et à
tous les acquéreurs
aujourd'hui deux collectivités locales
il ya les lycées les collèges les
hôpitaux
et comme il ya l'entreprise il ya
aujourd'hui des milliards c'est vrai
qu'ils peuvent aujourd'hui ça prouve et
localement le tout c'est d'assurer
d'assurer l'offre telle que vous l'avez
international par exemple difficile donc
ce système ne marche pas très bien
aujourd'hui et devrait marcher mieux je
crois que je cite la région aujourd'hui
à poursuivre l'oeuvre qui a été commencé
nous avons mis en place pour faire en
sorte que l'offre soit suffisamment
conséquente durable est pour pouvoir
assurer à paris en gestion à paris mais
pourquoi paris au sénat par exemple
parce qu'elle a continué à quand une
restaurant du sénat est plutôt bonne
réputation je sais pas je sais pas
répond locale le restaurant du sénat je
répondais éventuelle n'est pas le
restaurant du sénat
il est indépendante allemands tels
appels d'offres qu'ils étaient gérées
par des indépendants
d'où viennent la vienne que quelque part
donc c'est ça qu'on veut c'est qu'un
moment c'est pas vous qui gérez mais à
un moment si vous vous dites moi je veux
manger français si côté jeunes
agriculteurs sont et ouvrir les camions
à l'entrée de la cantine vous cette
veste du ministère de l'intérieur enfin
bref économie et finances 90 % y avait
rien qui venait de france il ya un
moment il faut bien voir et on se bat
leye je rappelle que dans les grandes
surfaces responsable écolo 10 dans les
grandes surfaces en france aujourd'hui
80 10 % de la viande et français passent
90 sur les collectivités à
saint-apollinaire par exemple comment ça
fonctionne ah oui c'est un peu lunaire
développe dans le cadre de son marché de
restauration scolaire des principes de
circuits courts et d'accès à des
produits type crc les blés les blés
culture raisonnée ou bio je trouve qu'il
ya quelque chose qui à l'intéressant de
notre conversation
c'est effectivement de privilégier
rechercher tout ce qui peut améliorer le
le revenu de l'agriculteur mais
attention à ne pas généraliser
parce qu'on parlait tu as l'air de
modèle économique on parlait de la
diversité des agricultures en france les
situations sont jamais les mêmes d'un
secteur à un autre quand on est paysan
apporter relié à genlis à châtillon ou à
auxerre on est dans des situations
complètement différente et c'est là où
il faudra que dans les temps qui
viennent on réfléchisse bien à quel
modèle économique on veut et il n'y a
pas un modèle économique comme on a pu
avoir jusqu'à présent ces retours d'une
d'un principe d'une exploitation type
familial 80 hectares c'est la moyenne en
france car c'est au contraire faire en
sorte que là où il ya des niches qui
peuvent être explorées eh bien on puisse
développer des particularités qui assure
à l'agriculteur une juste rémunération
j'illustre propos de rami la hausse est
content et c'est moi qui les ignorent
ministre aujourd'hui les seuls clients
les tirs qui fonctionne bien c'est le
comté on peut pas généraliser partout
est ce que je voudrais dire en
conclusion de l'émission quand même
c'est que pourquoi cette crise est si
violente est si grave parce qu'elles
touchent en même temps toutes les
productions le prix des céréales atteint
des niveaux records à descendre le prix
du blé dramatique aujourd'hui le prix de
la viande va mal le tout les toutes les
filières sont mises à mal en même temps
ce qui prouve tout explose au dos qu'il
faut que les français comprennent que
toutes les filières agricoles sont
aujourd'hui touchés par la crise et
qu'il doit y avoir des réponses
structurelles évidente
je reprends l'est nos structures rémy en
nouvelle-zélande pour les producteurs de
lait une coopérative en france 350
coopérative les structures regarder
autour comme elle fonctionne on verra
bien je donne ça comme exemple qui sera
bonne la fin pour montrer qu' il ya des
réformes structurelles aussi à faire
très important et nous en reparlerons
puisque le salon ne fait que commencer
dix jours à la porte de versailles nous
y reviendrons largement il ya un
département à l'honneur sur le stand
bourgogne franche comté à chaque jour
catherine matausch il sera en direct
dans la suite du 12/13 sur france 3 nous
y reviendrons dans nos différents
journaux puis en quête de région d'ath
redit à 23h15 demandera à quoi sert le
salon de l'agriculture aujourd'hui de
ces compléments sur france 3 point fr
vous pouvez revoir cette émission
excellent week end sur france 3